これじゃパクリですよね絶対ありえないことあるんですよ例えば僕が動画で女の人と
一緒に出てるって想像できますか
mars 脱いだんですよまずできないんですけど今日あえてそれをしてみようと思い
ますなんと今日のジェットはこちらの方でどうぞ
ブーブーなんでさん
こいつのマネージャーさんた兄が家に来ているかと言うと大阪に行っちゃうぞあかんっ
ててね台風で閉店していろいろ動かなくなって言い換えがになって
に急遽きたっていうのがない
観光地するとこういう何か聞かれたんですよねだけこのマネージャー何がすごいかって
いうと
見てくださいこの髪の毛たちのかわいいです x てくるがすごいんですよ
すごいまずですぐすべすべと見抜きがあってよくをよくお願いだけど
凍っ
ねもう一個の方ねーよおーこっち見てくださいよ
おっ
フィル被ってなんですかつ言葉でこんなに考えてきれいな人見たことないんですよはい
ありがとう
でも女の子でも僕言われますか女子にその2てくれさあ裏山して言ってるって言われる
んだんだ可愛いねカワイイ
さて母は ef ぱいやねパパ本当に本当に女の子になるんですよ
このトリッカーと力してあっての初めはみゅーずめんとタイプん今から交換でるんです
けどこの子と一緒に住んでしてねパパこうやってたら多分どう見ても僕はティスって
開くしてるの見てにょちゃ
ああああああ
なんと挿入してるってなるんですよ今度存知と楽しみましょってねまずはちょっと服装
を寝てる感情を出すために
ぞ女のコっと1本変遷してもらいましたドンキで買ってきました
必要はーいこれは5つじゃあ行きます絶対にはこの時数
これ遅いなーこれはで揉めずでもねそうけどパワーちょっと金アカンこっちへ省の関税
まず色的問題とキャラクターもえっとなんつってっつっ
スタンバイああああこれはいました別名が入ってましたよいやーこれ絶対こっちでいい
でしょ
うん意見じゃじゃじゃじゃーんうーん安全に説明変えましたよね6つだ
これですよね
[音楽]
めんどくなったらやめます
さっほー
いやいけるいける白い華奢な指先
そして
だ肌もズボンからの3自治の服
そこの萌え袖からの胸吊らからのおっさんですね音なんですよ後ろをみてください
妹っぽいなんか妹からですこれ今いい
今御ながら今女でいつ今んですね太さと行さあなぜ
ターゲット朝にくるんですけど
その前にちょっといないメンバーに1回チェストですかけてみようと思いますよ
ん
すっと入ってくる
[音楽]
別途うち屋さんですか
えっ
バッハ申し訳ないですもしました
すー
[音楽]
あろん
感じか本当にどちらさんですでみんよどうだったパット3 ar 全然本当に女の子だ
と申しましたはい
yeah サックス取るぜ通りですね
ホンジニョン
お邪魔してしまう yeah
pa
ん
b 1 f
カフェ
ん
ビッ
てん
で貼ってっ
で誰てのご
ございますん
[音楽]
女取れんちゃう
パレッシュってなん
ではに何やって持っ
ん
ましたね
おはよう
持った
[音楽]
分
me
ううううううっ
ええええええ
あっはぁ
どこが入っちゃっはい